at the End of
Time 13
O that was what so that looks good oh
okay yeah hi everybody y if you're in
the United States of course it's
Thanksgiving Eve it's Festivus it's
festiv us for the rest of us right yeah
we're going to pig out tomorrow yeah
hooray yeah got all kinds of food ready
to go and everything is one of my
favorite things yeah got a pumpkin pie I
made a pumpkin pie made a uh what do you
call
it I don't know peie pie yeah it's a
refrigerator over there got the stuffing
made just got her dice up and boil some
Tomatoes or potatoes for tomorrow to
make mashed potatoes with and then cook
the turkey stuff and cook the turkey
stuffing is done cuz you got to have the
real mashed potatoes yeah there
cornbread stuffing too need Jiffy
cornbread nice yep she's been up here
all day working just like Grandma used
yeah yeah I got it it's ready yeah it's
going to be good going be a lot of
leftover food well that's what we like
we eating that [__] for weeks I like the
leftovers almost as much well no maybe
slightly more than the actual meal
although the actual meal is good too put
the Cranberries put the gra CR berries
in the pot fresh cranberries sugar and
just cooked them till they exploded and
then just refrigerated it and that's how
you how you get your cranberry sauce
yummy yeah it's good I'm excited yeah I
got a little bit of spice excited about
eating all the food and just laying
around watching the MST 3K Turkey Day
Marathon which I do every year I usually
just leave it playing in the background
because I've seen some of the episodes I
bought those frozen rolls with the dough
that's all right yeah those are good
those are good take we had those last
year right yeah yeah I liked those I
liked those yeah
Oracle said time I've got a batch of
your moo pork Heating in the oven right
now yeah hell yeah and Tammy says I'm
making your Brazilian cream corn again
oh yeah yeah yeah Thanksgiving I didn't
make it this year I know that's some
good [__] though I got the uh we made it
last year right uh yeah didn't you make
it last year I did that Russian beet
puree to beet dish I got that coming
yeah okay yeah and uh uh GRE bean
casserole got
that I got I got those sweet sweet
potatoes too I could do those yeah I
like the sweet potatoes but I want white
potatoes too that's the main thing we'll
just you know we yeah I mean I love
mashed potatoes sweet potatoes are good
too but you know Zach says cool makeup
Jen thank you very much yeah we're going
to momento Mory is having a special uh
holiday like holiday Eve event this
evening they wouldn't normally do the
event on Wednesday night but they like
to do it whenever there's a holiday the
next day so we're going to try and wrap
this up in 2 hours so we can leave by
9:30 that's cool that that's cool that
people
doing the uh Brazilian cream style corn
that's the that's the best cream style
corn it's so good it's so much better
than American cream sty so good it's you
make it with real cream yeah I'm sure
it's like a million times more fattening
but oh my God whole cornels and
everything lot of butter yeah it's it's
delicious but like I said probably milk
I don't even want to know how many
calories are in that [__] but it's
really good Thursday like I mean
Thanksgiving calories I guess they don't
count with that's what we're selling
ourselves anyway and we hardly ate
anything today like in preparation we
had a tiny ham sandwich and like a
handful of lemon cookies yeah that's
about it and and one drink this is my
first drink Camp guys said we buy a
whole bone in turkey breast not as much
waste 8 and a 12 pounds yeah yeah we
don't end up wasting pretty much
anything we eat for all of it um don't
you make uh I thought you made broth or
something like that with the The
Leftovers yeah no I make the um what do
you call
it I cook um you know the trimmings from
onions yeah
celery the the uh the turkey turkey neck
my dad loves it turkey neck the livered
the gizzard and the heart I uh make uh
what do you call it broth out of it and
then that's the base for uh um my
U gravy yeah make two different gravies
make a turkey gravy out of the pan
drippings and then uh I can also blend
all that stuff up the the vegetables and
then use that same dripping and then
make like a vegetable gravy that's good
too I have two of them sometimes I'll
put a little bit of little bit of
gizzard in it so it has a little every
now and then you'll hit a little chunk
yeah I don't like a whole lot of that
liver though yeah it it does kind of
overwhelm the flavor of you put it's
nice to have like a little bit of in
there I like to cook it in in in the in
the broth yeah the whole thing but I
don't like to cut it up and then make it
in the gravy I used to like it but I got
sick of it yeah I see what you're saying
I like the gizzard in it though it's
just kind of chewy chewy yeah Oracle
said we're being a bit weird for
Thanksgiving I'm making lion's head
meatballs with Nappa cabbage and rice ni
okay hey Tammy said that that cream
style corn was a big hit last year yeah
I mean I don't see how anybody could not
like
thaty it's so good it's just like
ridiculously North America's got some
[__] lessons to learn I could drink a
gallon of that easily yeah just all on
its own it's like it's so yummy make me
want to make some I got this I think I
got stuff to make well I mean if you
want to I'm not going I know got so much
[__] food that's the thing it's like
we we make so much food it's like hey
it's Thanksgiving and then it's like oh
my God three weeks later we're silly
we're still eating some of it we eat
most of it in the first few
days it's a it's a lot Zach says I'm
also super excited for tonight's topic I
think it's so fascinating yeah I mean
and this is just going to be I don't
know just kind of like a wide ranging
casual discussion about this cuz I like
this a lot too I'm not like an expert by
any means about analog horror and I
haven't even you know seen the whole
like you know all of like a lot of the
big series and everything I've watched
some of them but not like all of them
but um but I don't know I think this' be
kind of like a fun discussion just cuz I
I like the whole aesthetic of it and I
like the whole idea behind it um if you
haven't seen it and if you're really
into analog horror there's an awesome
documentary and it's on YouTube and I
think it's just called the history of
analog horror and it's like 3 hours long
and it's super super in-depth and like
they talk to a lot of the creators and
they talk to like nexo like the guy that
does nexo and all that kind of stuff and
um it's really really good like they go
really in-depth into a lot of stuff and
it's like I've watched it a couple of
times at this point but they're it's
pretty um thorough and like pretty
exhaustive so Zach says did I ever check
out any of librarian's videos by the way
I didn't get a chance to but I
definitely will going forward because
like I said I there there's so much
content out there that's the thing about
analog horror and I feel like
particularly people in the online horror
Community analog horror it's hilarious
to me
how these these youth today but the
youths but they're always just kind of
like man the you know analog horror o it
came out way back in 2016 which it's
wasn't that long ago I mean yeah that's
not way back I'm like if you're talking
about way back I'm talking about like
way way back 90s yeah that's way back
sure but it's just kind of like saying
way back in 2016 and it's like at at
this point I feel like a lot of horror
creators think that anal horror has
become oversaturated and has become
stale which I get but I don't think
that's the thing I kind of feel like
analog horror at this point it's kind of
its own sub genre or actually I would I
think I would call it a Sub sub genre
because it's almost like a sub genre of
found footage which is in itself a sub
genre of horror you know what I'm saying
so I kind of feel like just like any
other sub genre like for example a
slasher movie or something like that
it's like yeah there's there'll be one
that comes out and it's like a big huge
hit and then everybody rips it off and
that happens for a few years everybody
gets [__] sick of it and then
everybody's like oh my God I don't ever
want to see another slasher movie ever
again but then like a few years go by
and then like somebody kind of reinvents
and like injects some new life into it
and I think that's probably what will
end up happening with analog horror
because I really do like the aesthetic
behind it I like the idea behind it I
like the idea behind online Horror in
general because it's so collaborative
and because there's like a low and they
said this on the documentary there's
like a really low barrier to entry
particularly as far as analog horror
goes because it uses so much um footage
that already exists like public domain
footage like old TV broadcasts and
things like that and like you know
cutting them up and remixing them like
in different way the vapor wave of well
I was going to say that it's like
actually really related to the whole
onset because it all kind of happened at
once um where the whole Vapor wave thing
came it got really popular and you know
uh and analog horror got really popular
and then that just that whole aesthetic
which I think the um the 80s looking
aesthetic which you know if you watch
new retro wave or something that ' 80s
look it has a name it's called outrun
but um there's also one that's kind of
more 90s centered and I think that's
just called aesthetic except it's got
like a bunch of spaces in it so it's
that but it's like that all kind of like
worked in Tandem and I think it's sort
of came about because a lot of people
that make analog horror content like
series and stuff are young like a lot of
the big ones in the genre were made by
like teenagers you know what I mean yeah
well they have time well yeah that's one
thing and and [__] things and things
are new to them so everything's exciting
oh we're going to make this me and Jen
could sit around look at that old
footage and not see anything in it
because it's like was we saw it the
first time around yeah yeah but I well I
think the thing about it is that um what
what they were saying on the documentary
and I think there might be something to
this it's like kids that grew up um you
know that didn't live through the ' 80s
and '90s that didn't live through the
analog era it could be that they are so
over saturated or over stimulated by
imagery you know memes and everything
just everything is just like out there
in their faces all the time that they
kind of want to hearken back to like the
old days when everything was like kind
of slower and more simple and yeah and
simpler and stuff like that's kind of a
relief for them so it might be that
might be why there's just this big
Resurgence in younger people being into
old stuff old [__] like stuff from like
the like the whole aesthetic of I mean
look how popular [__] stranger things
was um you know with a younger
demographic even though it was set in
the 1980s and like they wouldn't have
lived through that like we did yeah but
somebody invented a word for it but I
don't remember what it was it was the
fact that young people were having
feelings of nostalgia for a time in
which they did not live yeah there's a
word for that I think it's a German word
but I can't I know what you're talking
it off in comments might know what it is
I just heard somebody say it today but
what's funny is that it kind of works on
us old people too um I kind of I like I
see this stuff and it feels nostalgic to
me like Vapor wave which is a good music
they would play it as a background music
for dead Mall videos and [__] for you
old people who don't know what [__]
Vapor wave is it's recycled music you're
like what well think about it if you
want to make a song Why make a new song
when there's so many old forgotten songs
that you can modify songs that were just
like musac tracks and just forgotten
[__] from the80s and the 90s that just
totally forgotten and unused where you
could take that take a clip and slow it
way down and just repeat it over and
over again and just butcher a song up
and just break it down to its very
rudimentary feelings you know and make a
song out of that a good example would be
like Macintosh that the the most epic
paper wave song is by a band I think
it's called Macintosh Plus or it's not a
band it's just a Creator Macintosh Plus
and they just took some old kind of like
R&B musac B song b Lev song and slowed
it down and just repeated the same like
three or four lines over and over again
and then
just it's it's quite cool uh Vapor wave
is
uh it's a good way to put it has a
feeling to it yeah it's a Vibe for sure
and it's they' purposely make it sound
like you're listening to it off of a
tape and that there's something wrong
with the tape or that it's like or
you're hearing it from like off in the
distance or you're hearing it off in the
distance in a cheap mono speaker at the
store right like a music so it reminds
you like people our age it kind of
reminds you of being a kid and being in
the mall with your mom picking out bras
or whatever cheap and hearing this like
musac like coming through over the store
speakers so you never heard if if you're
older person you never heard Vapor wave
check it out it's it's on YouTube and
like I said I kind of feel like the the
whole Vapor wave thing like went along
with the whole analog horror thing you
know what I mean because it's basically
taking yeah they it's basically taking
old forgotten stuff like I said they use
musac they use um you know like
commercial Jingles they use like old
action movie soundtracks like from the
80s and stuff like that and just kind of
like remix them and do different like
things to them and analog horror is
pretty much the same thing a lot of it
now some creators do make their own
stuff like you know make their own
things and make it look old but a lot of
them do use a lot of like public domain
um type of footage like old training
films and things like that commercials
from a long time ago and putting them
together but making it like Sinister
nobody's going to nobody's going to sue
you because you're not making any money
off this yeah and that's another thing
too all forgotten [__] the companies
that made this [__] are long gone I love
too that people will spend years and
years of their lives doing these series
and a lot of them don't really get
anything out of it they just want to do
it they post them on YouTube for free
people watch them people talk about them
every now and then uh like Zach
mentioned the the kid that did the back
rooms uh one the main one he didn't
invent the back rooms but he was the one
that made the most popular uh series
about it he's um getting a deal with a24
like they're making a film adaptation of
that and the same thing happened with
you know one of the big ones in the
genre which isn't quite analog horror it
has analog horror elements but it's kind
of more an ARG which was Marble Hornets
and they actually did make that into a
movie later on uh which I saw and it was
not great but you know what I mean Jenny
you're you look real cute with those
glasses and that Club makeup out here do
you guys think that that look looks cute
she she was going like I don't think it
look good with the bags well no I just
thought that because you told me before
that when I had my bangs down and I had
the round glasses on you said that looks
crazy like you done I showed you you've
done photo shoot I know must just been
the way must have been the the outfit
you had on or something maybe it was or
maybe my hair didn't look as good May
was dirty or something I think it's a
really cool look the black the blackened
out eyes and stuff yeah this is the
second time I did eyes like I did it one
time and then I tried to put on the um
the false lashes and the glue got in my
eyeball and it just all of it ran so I
had to take everything she's wearing a
really cute outfit too J you got to
stand up show him that outf no let's not
let's not do let's not do that one leg
sticks out of it and it's got all the
leg goes through like a little holster
looking thing and it's a booty yeah it's
all
booty it's cute I'm going to get the
porn cam down [__] he going to get
the porn cam down porn cam Down Show to
just stand up stand show I have to it's
cool yeah yeah all right this is a cute
outfit he's always making me S we're
going to the club okay hold on let me oh
it's like all stuck up in my
oh back up stuck up in my ass
crack CL classic like that yeah
up show them the boots yeah this my
little velvety boots how far back I got
to now you have to lift them just lift
your leg there you go yeah yeah the cute
little boots that was a cute outfit I
bought that outfit for yeah I haven't
worn this out yet this is I've had it
for a while but those silver bracelets
or they um no I don't well I have a
couple little ones but I might get yet
you have to see what they look like um
Oracle knew the wor that we were talking
about anima anima that's the name of it
like like yeah Nostalgia for stuff that
you never experienced does anybody know
the name of that Vapor W song by
Macintosh Plus that I'm thinking about
go baby come
on I can't I don't even know what the
name of that song was I don't even know
the original song
right it's just some kind of R&B jingle
and they slowed it way down and it
sounds like it's playing out of a damn
mono speaker at the mall yeah I'm kind
of I'm kind of it's addictive L like I
said it really kind of gives you a
certain feeling which is what it's
supposed to do it's supposed to evoke
that which in the same way that analog
horror is supposed to evoke the feeling
of you in your room in the dark when you
were a kid in the middle of the night
and like some weird [__] came on the TV
and you weren't sure what it was you
know what I mean they were trying to
like get that across they also did a
Billy Idol one and all it is is Billy
Idol going and I spend so much time
that's
it you know her [__] eyes with
without her face just that little I
spend so much time that's it then it
goes on and it Eyes Without a Face is
kind of in there it's mixed in with a
couple of other musac songs
Weird um thank you very much Bryce that
is awesome of You Happy Thanksgiving
love the show as always thank you very
much we always do app all from New
Zealand yeah that's awesome that's
awesome yeah Zach said I think the first
time I heard about Vapor wave stuff was
Dan videos yeah because he uses it a lot
in his um stuff well all the dead Mall
videos kind of yeah well I guess it kind
of like I said became sort of saturated
because everyone was doing that but his
editing is also kind of vapor wave of
all the dead Mall videos like his VD he
always like finds these weird ass
[__] um old commercials like he used
like those Psychic Friends commercials
with Dion Warwick and he found this
really old weird Blockbuster employee
training video and he like us pieces of
that it's just like [__] crazy [__]
and he like just the way he edits them
in like old talk shows and stuff like
daytime talk shows and the way he edits
them is like super funny but um but yeah
so oh before we get too much into the
topic like I said this is going to be
just kind of a wide ranging me and Tom
watched I mean I watched the documentary
I watched a bunch of stuff about it
today like a bunch of documentaries
about it last night together we watched
um there was like an hour and a half uh
iceberg
which was basically talking about um
kind of the best known uh analog horror
series and you know obviously went from
it's an iceberg so they went from like
the best known ones like down to the
more obscure ones so they kind of talked
about that a little bit so that was kind
of fun because I just wanted Tom to get
because I wasn't sure how familiar he
was with I had never heard of it right
so I just kind of wanted to give him
like a little bit of a primer like an
idea but some of the little cases they
talked about go way back I remember them
like the the fake Max Headroom video
where they busted in on a real
television uh signal that's old that was
kind of
before hor thing but it got I guess it
it is on the same yeah it's usually it's
usually cited as kind of like a
precursor because here's the thing and I
I liked they explained this really well
in the documentary they said technically
that's not analog horror because analog
horror is just made to mimic something
that looked like from that era whereas
but that was from that era so like by
the same token something like like a
found footage movie from you know uh
like uh The Blair Witch Project that is
also not considered it's considered like
a prototype but it's not considered
analog horror because it was made in the
analog era same with ghostwatch uh the
very famous s sort of it's not really
found footage I don't think I'd call
it's kind of like a mockumentary or like
a mock live broadcast um but it has a
lot of the same [__] that you would see
in analog horror to be analog horror it
has to be replicating that it can't be
from that actual era you know what I
mean it's trying to evoke the feeling of
that but not be from that actual ER you
get it some what's funny is these kids
they they missed '90s internet yeah '90s
internet was like that it and it did
have that feel the internet was a
mysterious place man in 96 97 even up to
early 2000s it was like never quite were
sure what you were going to see and they
had weird weird ass [__] sites like
Gore gallery and they had what do they
call them discussion groups back then
yeah and billboards and [__] it was just
the internet was just done differently
it more crude but it was it was fun it
was it was the Wild
West weren't as many people on it either
right you know it was like you were
getting away with something and like I
said I kind of think that that's what a
lot of people that um that are analog
horror creators they're trying to
evoke that time period in the 80s and
90s when you weren't really
sure if what you were seeing was real or
like what the context of it was like now
I kind of feel like everyone is just
like oversaturated with information and
you can find out anything you want to
know like pretty much in seconds but
back then you didn't really have that
yeah and so you know you'd be watching
TV at 3:00 a.m. or something because you
had insomnia and you saw some weird
[__] [__] on there and just like what
the [__] was that all about like and
there' be no way of finding out so I
think that they're trying to and even
like the guy that did um that did local
58 which we'll talk about in a minute
Chris stob I think his name is he was um
I was watching like an interview with
him and he said the idea for local 58
came from when he was a kid he's younger
than us but he still remembered you know
analog stuff like he's not that much
younger than I us was and um he said
that where he grew up there was like
there was this local channel and it's
like they showed we like weird like um
you know those film strips that they
used to show in classroom like in the
70s and stuff that were like moral
dilemas and then like it would end wash
your hands and all kind of [__] well
well yeah but these were like moral D
like what would you do and then like
then it just kind of stops like before
some bad [__] happens and then you're
supposed to turn off the projector and
like you know ask the class like what
they would do but he's like I was a
little kid and I just saw these on the
TV without any context so it's just kind
of like there's these kids getting into
these horrible situations and then it
just ends and you never find out what
happened to them and it's just like so
seeing that as a kid and not knowing
what it was he's like obviously I know
now what they were but it's like back
then I didn't so he's like so I was
trying to evoke that same feeling that I
got as a kid watching those and not
knowing what they were so I think that
that he put that like really well the
way he was like explaining that um all
right so like I said before we get too
much into it it's just going to be a
whole all over the place if you guys
have any um series that you would
suggest uh like I said I've seen I
haven't seen a lot of them but I have
seen bits and pieces of like kind of the
big ones and stuff like that but if you
have any that you think are really good
like let me know and I'll watch them and
we can talk about that but before we do
that uh we got to do our little
Advertiser affiliate kind of thing and
this actually kind of fits in really
well because on the off chance that you
wanted to start your own analog horror
project obviously You' probably need to
know how to do video editing for one
thing uh and maybe graphic design some
other creative things like that and if
you don't know how to do those those
things then maybe maybe you could go and
subscribe to our sponsor skillshare uh
who or this online repository thousands
and thousands of different classes of
various creative things including video
editing graphic design productivity
figure painting whatever it is you want
to do in a creative thing they have a
class for it and they have classes
geared toward every from the beginner to
the expert and they are all taught by
trained professionals so if you click my
link down in the description box they
are doing their Black Friday Cyber
Monday deal until November 30th and if
you click the link down there you
actually get 50% off a monthly or an
annual subscription uh full disclosure
obviously if you click on that link we
get a small commission uh if you sign up
for skillshare but please click the link
get 50% off take some classes make your
own analog horror stuff it'll be really
cool so yeah now as we mentioned
before so analog horror would be defined
as pretty much any and there's there's
been films like feature films uh like
skamar rank or broadcast signal
intrusion um you know ones like that
that kind of toy with that
aesthetic but it's largely an online
phenomenon almost entirely um web series
uh usually on YouTube
and as I mentioned it can't
be it doesn't really count as analog
horror if it was like footage from that
time if you just found some you know a
random videotape at a garage sale and
just like uploaded it that's not
necessarily analog horror because it is
analog it came from that time period the
whole point is you're trying to take
that footage and mix it into a story
that is trying to replicate something
from that era but is not necessarily
from that era although pieces of a good
from that era does that make any sense
okay so yeah now there have
been kind of uh precursors and I like
that um the documentary that I watched
they actually went so far as to go all
the way back to uh you know the very
famous Orson Wells War of the World
broadcast um you know not saying that's
analog horror obviously but kind of
citing as an early example of what they
would later call
unfiction which is
basically it's kind of overlaps with
creepy pasta in the sense that you're
telling a story or you're making a
narrative online but you're in Universe
you're trying to make people believe
that it's real you know what I mean like
it's it it's not supposed to be
presented as Fiction it's supposed to be
presented as this is really happening
and analog horror is kind of a subset of
that so as an early example of fiction
they cited War of the Worlds the Orson
Wells broadcast of War of the Worlds
because the way that it was presented
they were clearly trying to make it seem
as though it was a real radio broadcast
and that happened what like back in the
1930s right so this isn't a New Concept
by any stretch of the imagination it was
just kind of the internet that made it
like really
explode another example that they cited
which is obviously not analog horror but
had like a lot of was probably like a
big inspiration on the analog genre was
the David cronberg movie video
drum because if you think about it the
whole premise Behind Video
drum is that this guy comes across like
a pirate broadcast or like a a channel
that has all of this kind of like
torture and porn and [__] like that on
it and then it turns out that watching
it like gives you like a virus like it
has a physical effect on your body and
that is a very very analog horror uh
Trope like it would become one later on
so I'm not saying that David kenberg
like invented the [__] genre but if
you watch video Drome that has a lot of
the [__] that would turn up later on
they Rift off a video Dr maybe maybe
unconsciously though that maybe yeah cuz
chances of them seeing that although you
know it's just in the Zeitgeist yeah
sure that's what I'm saying
because like I said and I mentioned
watch which from
1992 which I did um I actually did a um
a video about that on my other channel
scar Salon but if you don't know that
was that was uh broadcast
on uh British TV in Octo on Halloween
night of 1992 and it was presented as
though it was a real live broadcast of a
poltergeist investigation like they were
investigating you know a poltergeist
infestation based Loosely on the nfield
case and over the course of the live
broadcast more [__] like scarier [__]
started happening and then like all the
real people and they even use real
newscasters and [__] like that like from
that era yeah to make it seem like to
give it some very similitude and if you
haven't seen ghost watch please watch it
because you will be astounded at how
ahead of its time time it was it's just
it's so
immersive and like it really until like
it goes kind of crazy at the end but
it's like up until that it's totally
believable so believable in fact that
the story goes when they first aired it
in 1992 a whole bunch of people thought
it was real and started calling the BBC
and were freaking the [__] out because
they were like ho because it they built
it up really nice and it's like like I
said these were all real newscasters
they looked like they were really doing
their yeah it's Halloween and we're here
you're investigating this silly
Poltergeist thing isn't this funny and
they were like having a good time and
then scarier and scarier [__] started
happening they're like uhoh like and
then and they even had like people
calling in to the show and saying oh my
God weird [__] is happening at my house
too and like all so it was like kind of
becoming like Nationwide it was a
[__] brilliant concept kind of like
my dad and that damn mermaid that
mermaid [__] documentary that thing
that was on Discovery you saw that [__]
on yeah you know that mermaids that's
real man
what I flabbergasted he believed it
though they had doctors and everything
scientist I went and watched it I looked
it up it was it was made for Monster
week or something yeah yeah he didn't
know though he thought it was he thought
it was real and uh saw the doctors and I
said I said dad all those doctors man
like he like that woman he goes that's
an actress I thought she was kind of
goodlooking to be a doctor
I mean the thing about it I guess if you
didn't grow up and we're older you know
obviously we're gen we're Gen X but we
kind of grew up on both sides of the
Divide you know we grew up like half in
the analog world and half in the digital
world so we kind of grew up with the D
so we kind of like there at the
Inception yeah and I feel like if you
grew up if you were you know the
generations prior to us if you didn't
grow up in that environment yeah um it
it doesn't really hit the same they they
don't really seem to get it as much I
got fooled too though he gave me a book
this is before I joined the army I was
living in Mississippi he gave me a book
you going to like this book man this is
some weird [__] it's called Eaters of
the dead it's about these Vikings this
this Arab guy goes hang out these
Vikings and they they fight these guys
and it's from it's old from way back the
stories from way back and and they they
fight these Neals and he goes yeah they
believe it's a Neal
so I read it and I was like yeah that
probably what they're talking about but
that whole book was fiction it was just
yeah made and they based the movie 13th
Warrior on it yeah with Antonio Banderas
was not a bad movie I like that movie
actually it departs from the book quite
a bit but in certain areas but uh uh it
Eaters of the Dead
is it's given to you as if it was
somebody telling you about a historical
document that they found that said all
this right and I I didn't have any
context I just thought it was telling me
the truth I thought it was a scientific
document talking about this old story
that they
found kind of like a found kind of like
the way Dracula was originally written
probably supposed to be read back in the
day Dracula is supposed to be WR almost
kind of like found footage yeah it's
like the literary equivalent of found
footage because it's all right letters
and Diaries and stuff like that and
newspaper articles it's presented like
it's like a real yeah so like I said
it's nothing Dead's kind of like that
too it's nothing new right so I kind of
feel like a lot of time but I think it's
harder to detect from back in the day
because you're not real cognizant of how
Savvy people were back then about it's
like you um kind of determining like
whether a thing was fact or fiction like
maybe everybody knew well obviously
everybody knew Dracula was fiction but
I'm just saying that you know something
like that that was presented as being
factual would people have necess neily
been like oh like they knew what that
was like you know now like everybody
knows the Blair Witch Project isn't a
real documentary yeah like you can't
believe these those old 1800s newspapers
no not at all about airships and UFOs
they just made [__] up they made [__] up
they were just trying to sell papers
yeah that they like I said it's no
different it's no different that they
were digging a train tunnel and found
dinosaurs in there you know living
dinosaurs that was another one I believe
that I think we did a show for a while
until until gen uncovered this Freudian
fian [__] what itan forian
Archaeology named after that Fort guy
yeah yeah yeah he was using all that it
just making things up to [__] to uh
to back up the bibl why they were doing
it really yeah it was like a creationist
kind of [__] yeah Oracle said the
Phantom of the Opera has that Vibe too
the original book is presented as
investigative journalist right right
yeah I feel like that was kind of a
trend yeah so it's not really I mean
found footage
is not new uh it was just kind of
presented in a different way but you
know it's yeah it's it's pretty much the
same you're you're just kind of like
showing oh look I found this cache of
documents and here they are right you
know what I mean yeah actually uh when I
read Gaston
lose Phantom of the Opera translated
from French into English at the time I
believed it was something based that had
really happened uh and it the the
location that they're talking about that
they're talking about do exist other
people come came later and debunked them
like you know the the cave where the
where where where the Phantom supposedly
lived there was something
underneath some building that was climed
but it was not a cave about the size of
this room is what they were talking
about it wasn't as big as it was in the
book where it had an underground Lake
and an island in the middle of the
underground Lake where he had a house
that he had built with you know an orgon
and torture chambers and [__]
no it wasn't that big and it was
fiction but it was it was written in a
way like it
historical you know uh like a historical
document yeah you know like like it was
crime like it was based on something
that actually did happen and he swears
over and over again that this did happen
I thought maybe it was because it sounds
like a serial killer right it fits the
mo but they knew kind of what the MMO of
a serial killer was by that time they
didn't call it that they didn't call it
that right but they knew how to make a
fake serial killer based on guys like oh
[__] what's his name down
there do uh the guy who had the tortury
castle what was his name HH Holmes HH
Holmes yeah Herman
mudget yeah F of the Opera was a lot
like J HH Holmes similar which I kind of
suspect that a lot of the stuff about HH
Holmes was exaggerated as well not
saying he wasn't a serial killer cuz he
totally was I'm just saying a lot of the
stuff might have been a little bit of
cuz like I said that's they did that
back then to sell papers just like they
do nowadays it's like it's like I said
it's no different and that's the thing
that you know something like analog
horror even though it's clearly a newish
phenomenon um really the earliest
examples of what we would Now call
analog horror probably only stem from
like the mid 2000s I want to say and it
didn't really take off until kind of
recently you know there was little
projects here and there that kind of
people were into but it didn't really
take off until probably 2016 2017
somewhere around there but there have
been you know things similar to that
going all the way back to like recorded
history I feel like even though you
wouldn't even call it the same thing
like I said I always say that Dracula is
like a found footage novel like
definitely yeah and honestly you know a
lot of people talk about Blair Witch
Project being like the first found
footage movie but it's absolutely not
Cannibal Holocaust was a found footage
movie and That Was 1980 that was exactly
it was exactly the very definition of a
found footage movie you know these
people went to study the cannibals and
we found their footage and they all got
killed and eaten you know what I mean
here it is and we're presenting it so
yeah that's exactly what that is but the
thing about Blair Witch Project is that
not only and I like The Blair Witch
Project But Not only was it a good found
footage movie but they also marketed
it like the way they marketed it was
[__] genius they marketed it like it
was real they said and this was like
kind of the early days of doing nobody
had really done this before you know
they set up a website these people are
missing and [__] like that they told the
actors you know you stay in hiding for
like a year so it seems like you're
really missing it's like we want to make
this seem like a real thing they made a
documentary like a mockumentary about
this Legend like it was a real legend so
if you weren't from that area I mean
some people thought it was real you know
what I mean this is real footage that we
found and it's like this was a real
legend that these people were making a
documentary about and [__] like that it
was just like a brilliant marketing Ploy
and obviously it was because what the
movie was made for what $300,000 and it
made like 200 80 million or some [__]
like that tire many times over you know
what I mean it's like they made it for
like peanuts it's relatively I was in
Mississippi at the time and I remember
uh my ex-wife's all her little friends
all her little goth friends you know
likeing uh Melissa and Melissa and
Michelle were hyping this movie to me
before before they they went to go see
it and they liked it but I didn't go see
it yeah um I think I saw it later on on
uh VHS or something and I was like good
thing I didn't go to the theater to see
this I didn't like it but they liked it
in the theater I'd imagine that probably
in theater when it was new and they had
evidently been seeing stuff online for
it they've been releasing stuff online
yeah and they were kind of thought it
might have been real that it might have
been based on something that was real
yeah people weren't sure yeah and I was
trying to navigate my way through it you
know I was older than them you know
[__] wiser you know come back from
the Army and [__] my third you know late
20s early 30s late 20s at that time I
was like no that's that's got to be
something
fictional um but uh looking back on it I
probably should have gone with them they
did a good they did a good job like
making it seem like it really happened
though yeah they were like you ever
heard that that that thing's really
happened theair that's a brilliant marke
oh man it's it's on the
internet at that time I was like what's
on the Internet it's probably [__]
was the thinking back
then that's not real that's not real not
real that's wild west [__] yeah it's all
those suing
nerds but I I mean I kind of feel like I
mean props to them because they were way
ahead of the curve on this one the fact
that they like I said not only set up a
whole mockumentary about the legend but
they also had a website about it with
like all you know the missing people and
they had everything looked real that
website gave them all that free
advertising that's how that blew the
[__] up and it just blew up yeah now the
thing I saw it in the theater um and I
liked it I don't I don't I I think the
the more times I see it like the less I
like it but I the guy um like I said I
think it was the guy that did that made
local 58 which you know is uh analog
horror series that I think it was him
that said on the documentary that he was
talking about the Blair Witch Project
and he said he didn't see it in the
theater he actually saw like a friend of
his got uh like a pirate copy and they
just watched it in their dorm room like
on a laptop and he's like he's like some
ways that made it scarier because it's
like it's almost like my friend found it
like found this footage you know what I
mean and was showing it to me he's like
I don't think it would have been quite
as scary if you saw it in a theater
because it would seem more like more
official more yeah like more like a
movie you know what I mean he's like
watching it on a laptop was like kind of
a lot scarier yeah there's something
about having a mysterious
Source yeah like that song that we
played the most mysterious song on the
internet which is it's a great dark wave
song it wouldn't be as great if you knew
who that was but all all the magic would
drain probably it's a good song yeah but
not knowing who it is adds to it and I
think I mean the
whole I mean the whole impetus behind
Horror in general but I think like
analog Horror in particular is that
people are a lot more fascinated by
mystery and ambiguity even if they don't
admit it CU I know that like sometimes
you see like an ambiguous horror like I
said I know that like the movie skar
rank which is kind of an analog horror
movie was was very polarizing with some
people being like Oh my God I'm just
like watching little kids feet for 90
minutes but um which corners of walls
and stuff but um but it you know it it
was just trying to get across a Vibe you
know but I kind of feel like the appeal
of analog Horror in particular and the
reason why a lot of it is left vague is
that things are a lot scarier and a lot
more appealing when you don't know
what's going on and I kind of feel like
the reason that a lot of people are
talking now about like how analog
Horrors may be kind of like getting a
little stale or something like that one
is that a lot of people are making
projects based on projects that already
exist and when they're doing that it's
kind of the same thing that happened
with the whole Slender Man thing where
you keep adding onto the story and
adding on to the lore and the more you
add on to the lore you're the more
you're taking the mystery away just like
with the xenomorph and the [__] Yao
[__] thing for a [__] Predator you
don't need to know anymore yeah it's
much SC the more you know the more lame
it is they really [__] up the
xenomorph [__] that's what I'm saying
and some and I was watching a couple
videos where they were talking about the
back rooms which of course is like the
the massive thing going on now which has
to do with Lial spaces which we'll talk
about in a minute but it's just kind of
like I feel like the the back rooms was
much creepier when it was just the
videos and nothing was explained they're
like oh my God it's just we slipped into
this or they call it no clipping where
they like I slipped into this quote
unquote like alternate Dimension that's
just these endless like rooms and
hallways and maybe there's a monster in
here chasing me but it's like it's not
explained any more than that like as the
as the you know story got more and more
popular and other people started adding
their own stuff onto it and making their
own projects based on it they're coming
up with all of these explanations and
lore and stuff like that and I don't
know and it it takes a lot of the
creepiness away because I think the
whole the whole point of Lial spaces
being creepy is that it's not you know
it's just it's an empty space but it's
an empty space that should have people
in it so it's kind of like weirds you
out when you see it and it's like creepy
and Abandoned and there's no people
there and it just gives you this really
creepy this really eerie feeling the
more you explain that the more you
explain the lore behind it it's not
creepy anymore shit's better when it's
like mysterious and I was talking about
this a little bit when I live streamed
yesterday about that movie yellow brick
road which leaves a lot of questions
unanswered and that seemed to piss a lot
of people off because they were like
what the [__] like they didn't get the
ending or they're just like um what's
going on what is this but I was like I
think that's way better don't explain it
you know what I mean it's much scarier
like if it's not explained and like I
said I think that's why a lot of people
liked anal horror because a lot of the
series and you know they at this point
it's almost kind of like got to a point
where it was like a parody of itself
because it just kept repeating the same
tropes over and over it's like oh here's
the you know the the emergency broadcast
sound and then like a creepy you know
like message on there talking about
aliens or whatever so it's just it it
kind of got and you know here's a
distorted face so it kind of got a bunch
of tropes and it got a little bit tired
but I think the reason that a lot of
people liked it previous was because it
wasn't explained to any great degree you
know what I'm saying that's much scarier
to me um so yeah
and a there's Pooky poy pants there's
poy Miss Pooky pants Ross yeah special
guest she's like can I get can I get
down now she attack Sho can I get down
leave those shoes alone she's like um
I'm just going to like tear up people
J's boots don't do it she's playing it
off like I wasn't going to yeah she
pretends like she wasn't going you were
going Tammy's like Pooky yeah she's
she's been kind of bad today yeah Zach
says that game control also played into
analog horror a lot too yeah yeah I was
looking a little bit about that I've
never played it but I was like looking
about um looking up about it earlier um
it's about a govern government Bureau
investigating the Paranormal that can't
use modern tech so it's all Tech from
the 50s and 60s yeah see very very
common I kind of feel like though that
after a while because here's the thing
if you're gonna Co if you're gonna make
an analog horror project there has to be
some kind of like found footage there H
like in a found footage movie there has
to be some [__] reason why somebody
is filming this [__] you know what I
mean and I think that that's where a lot
of the believability of found footage
goes out the window because at some
point if you're filming something if
like some giant like Cloverfield monster
is like coming after you you would stop
filming I mean and just run okay like
most people would you wouldn't keep
filming it so um so I like that some
good found footage mov movies do kind of
find a way around that where it has like
it gives a justification for why they
would keep filming so the thing about
analog horror is that the idea of it is
that it does the weird thing about it is
that and i' never really this never
really occurred to me until I read an
essay about it it doesn't have
characters per se it's almost like
information that's presented to you as
though it's immersing you as the
character yeah so you're trying to
present the story in a way that seems
like in an organic way that has a reason
for being on analog media so usually
what they'll come up with is here's some
tapes I found like at a garage sale like
VHS tapes that are really weird or
they'll present it as um like a like an
old TV station like that's pretty common
uh so so they'll do that kind of stuff
you know it it's usually like a found
footage type thing like we found these
and they're really weird and help me
explain them or somebody sent me these
and I don't know where they came from
and all that other kind of stuff there
was also one called which actually
wasn't a video it was actually a podcast
which started out called um archive 881
they actually made it into a Netflix
series later on which I saw and it's
actually pretty good um but I don't
think it was successful enough like to
get a second season but that was
basically like a guy who was hired by
this mysterious company which is again
pretty common that's very cron and
bergian and they kind of put him out in
this bunker like in the middle of
nowhere he's supposed to like archive
all of this weird ass footage so that's
a pretty common Trope too but like I
said there has to be some way of getting
you into the world that seems organic
like why you're seeing these old VHS
tapes and I feel like that's why a lot
of them use the old TV station Trope
local 58 was the first one that did that
and is probably like the best known one
and I think that was it wasn't the first
analog horror project but I think that
was the one that really kicked off the
the big wave that came afterward but the
thing about it was that so many people
liked that that there were like a
million ripoffs you know what I mean I
think the best known ripoff is was just
called Channel 7 but they were all kind
of the same because it's an easy in you
know it's just like oh it's this weird
old TV station like in some little dinky
town somewhere and here's all this weird
[__] we can show that like looks and you
can use like all of this public access
stuff and like public domain stuff that
you found so there's that kind of thing
too I've also seen oh we talked about
the max hrum incident before yeah I
don't remember if we I thought that we
had covered that in kind of a little
more depth on maybe a show we did about
Creepy internet Mysteries or something
like that a long timeo first because
it's so old yeah I mean we just talk
about that a little bit and like I said
that does that's kind of a precursor to
analog horror cuz that's that's the
thing that analog horror is trying to
replicate yeah the weird thing about the
max hedam incident and it was actually
it happened in ' 87 and there was
actually two breaking it was two
different stations right but they were
both in
Chicago and whoever this was who I'm
pretty sure they still don't know
exactly who it is I heard they have an
idea some there's a but he just but and
the thing about it is that the when he
broke into the into the
broadcast he didn't do anything Sinister
or creepy even I mean it's just it's
inherently it looks creepy it's
inherently weird because it's just
somebody in a Max Headroom costume for
no reason yeah like just saying random
[__] but it's
not I don't it's not like overtly
Sinister but I think people think it was
creepy just because there was no context
for it like why the you can't couldn't
understand much of what he says right
what what happened is like you said said
back in '
87 somebody broke into a local
television station transmission right
and I don't know how many people saw it
but a lot of people saw this mysterious
figure of a guy dressed up like max hrum
if you don't know who that is you're
[__] uh it was a guy who was supposed
to be a a a virtual reality image of a
guy kind of like something out of Back
to the Future too you know the the the
two guys that were fighting in the
80s retro Cafe the AA and the [__]
Reagan on TV may be clouding the issue
anyway
uh this guy appears on TV and he's just
rambling and he looks like Max hrum and
he's doing things like throwing shoes
and spanking himself in the ass and
talking about something you can barely
understand what he's saying there's a
lot of noise in the
background he evidently did it twice
they never did find out who it was
was
um I did see another program that had a
a good explanation of who it was it was
a a guy who used to work in the tech
department in that in that uh that
television station and he had a lot of
equipment to do that with and he knew
about broadcasting and the signals and
had jammed the signal and got in there
somehow and uh he had been fired from
that station and he was basically
trolling the station
that's that sounds about right but he'd
worked there evidently and evidently his
his only a few of his friends knew that
he did
that and uh once they started putting it
on the news they put it on the local
news that it was done he uh got scared
shitless and never did it again he was
evidently kind of like a shy guy he
wasn't like a nerd
yeah but uh did like something that you
did that they would picture The Joker
doing and an old Batman
uh [__] movie or
something you know interrup in a [__]
broadcast by your own means I don't know
how he's transman yeah I'm not sure
either cuz it was like a bigger
undertaking back then for sure yeah I
think they said they thought he was
transmitting from one of their towers
that he how to get into one of their
towers and he hijacked their towers it
was it was them broadcasting it but he'
take taken over the feed because he knew
how to do
it that's crazy yeah hi desert said I
like Gemini Productions on YouTube yeah
that's a that's a big one a lot of
people talk about that one Hugo said
when Peter Jackson made King Kong he
also made the Lost scene of the spider
in black and white of the original King
Kong with this might also be analog
horror I well I don't know about that no
maybe not the Lost spider scene I'd like
to see that is it out there I thought we
saw that like right around the time that
we were watching King Kong I thought
they put that back in yeah I thought
they put it I thought they put it back
in okay I thought it was in the version
that we watched but I don't remember
where that was you know what I mean cuz
I think we've reviewed King Kong like
not too long ago
right but um but yeah so the thing about
it you know like I said it's kind of
almost become a Trope at this point but
I don't want to [__] on the sub genre
too hard because of that because all
horror all movie subg genres all fiction
sub genres they all have tropes I mean
that's kind of how you categorize them
into different subg genres right I mean
you know slasher movies have tropes
obviously so you know analog horror is
going to have tropes as well usually
what it is uh it'll look like something
from either the 1960s to the 1990s
that's usually the the thing it's going
to look like it's on VHS or it's going
to look like an old TV broadcast a lot
of times not always um cuz some of them
look like old video games they do a lot
of that like cursed video games haunted
video games they do a lot of that kind
of stuff too um and there's a lot of
overlap also with args which is kind of
the same as a series but it's expanded
out to other media so something like The
Blair Witch Project would almost kind of
be like an ARG because it also had a
documentary and it also had like it had
media outside of the film itself you
know what I'm saying that was meant to
feed into the lore so that's kind of
like a similar thing but what it'll
usually have it's usually set up like
somebody finding a bunch of tapes or
like some weird kind of br
that's usually interrupted by something
now I'm going what here is the max hedum
incident want to see it they have a
recording of the original incident they
were playing a
game and this guy busts
in there's the G here he
comes okay so it's just black for a
while there he is then this comes
on
he that's it and you can't understand
what he's
saying well the um they did have
subtitles on some versions yeah yeah
yeah because the version that was on the
iceberg video we watched last night had
subtitles on it
yeah so they actually have figured out
what he said but like he said there's a
lot of background noise like a lot of
kind of annoying background noise that
he put in and then it goes back to the
News Zach says Tom clean your screen
yeah yeah it's got like your little
fingerprints and [__] all over probably
yeah claimed it but yeah so I feel like
the common Trope is that um and this is
kind of going back to local 58 which a
lot of other projects like I don't want
to say ripped off that seems a little
uncharitable but you know what I mean um
but it'll have a thing where it's
usually some kind of larger entity or
entities that are kind of trying to get
into our world so it's usually like
alien like an alien intelligence or it's
like some kind of love crafty in Elder
gods or something or it's some kind of
shady Corporation you know kind of like
you having stranger things like they
accidentally opened a rift to another
dimension like [__] like that although
you do see variations of it like there's
one I haven't seen the whole thing but
there's one called that's kind of more
recent I think it started in 2019 or
2020 maybe and it was called what they
it's called the Tangi virus I think it's
called and it said in Louisiana and that
's actually more about like these spores
that you get from like drinking the
water but then they like control they're
like mind control spores I guess it's
kind and I think there was another one
that had that same kind of thing because
isn't there that um that organism that
can control ants Yeah by like putting
that yeah and I think that's kind of
where that idea comes from a fungus or a
mold right so there's like a lot of
stuff about like some of them there's
kind of a little Sub Sub sub genre where
it's it's kind of like missing people
and murgers and stuff like that but it
seems like most of the really popular
ones are
more esoteric I guess it's because it
usually has to do with aliens wanting to
take over humans or like like I said
like some interdimensional beings or
some [__] like that there's actually one
and I don't even know if I'd call it
it's analog horror for sure but I don't
think it's a series I think it's just
one video and they showed some of it on
the um video we were watching last night
it was called Corner folk and it's
basically just a guy who is talking
about these transdimensional beings and
there's only certain ones that can go
from like parallel Dimensions like into
this other parallel Dimension and he
thinks that he has one in his house so
it's basically just like this short
video of him like filming around his
house and these Corner folk like kind of
coming out of the corners and stuff and
it's actually like pretty creepy and I
really dug it but so like I said you
just some of them are just really simple
like some of the series have been going
on for years and years and have like all
of this exhaustive lore and everything
and some of them were just like one
video you know what I mean I kind of
feel like one of the earliest ones and I
actually watched this one today I think
when it first started out and went viral
I'm pretty sure it was just one video I
think it's four now but it's called No
through Road and that was from I believe
the mid 2000 maybe 2006 2007 something
like that and it was basically made by
some British teenagers
and they're just all in a car and
they're kind of like you know hanging
out and doing [__] like teenagers do and
they come to this tunnel it's at night
and it's a you know that's I can't
remember the name of the tunnel but it's
just like no through road Private Drive
or whatever and they go through there
and then like it's only about 10 minutes
long and they keep circling back to the
same place again and they are freaking
out because they can't get out of this
Loop that they're in like they keep
driving and driving and they're just
like oh my God there's that sign again
there's that tunnel again you know what
I mean it's like really good because I
like I like that kind of stuff and then
like at the end like this weird person
like appears and kills them all because
like at the beginning it's just kind of
like hey these four kids were found dead
in their car like you know what we don't
know what happened to them but here was
their cell phone video you know what I
mean so that was a really
early um example of the genre because it
was presented as though it was real but
I feel like it took a long time for
other people to start making stuff you
know I think it really took local 58
which was kind of the first one
to present itself as archives of an old
T like local TV channel with just like
all this weird [__] and then like it was
normal at first but then it would start
doing stuff like um like the moon was
like a being that was trying to like
kill you and [__] like that so yeah yeah
yeah well that's what like the guy that
made it he was just kind of like I kind
of liked the idea of like the Moon being
like a malevolent being like some kind
of alien intelligence or some kind of
elder god or something like that so but
but he kind of had it where it's just
like regular ass um you know broadcast
like from some shitty little local
station from the ' 80s or whatever and
then there would just be weirder like
emergency broadcast signal and would be
like go outside look at the Moon you
know what I mean it would be like weird
[__] like that so it's like it's really
effective like the way they do it
because if it's done well and a lot of
it's done kind of badly but that's true
of any kind of horror if it's done well
it builds
up you know where it starts out kind of
normal like I said you're just at home
in the 80s watching some regular [__] on
TV and then all of a sudden like just
very slowly just weird [__] starts to
infiltrate like into the broadcast or
whatever so I think that was really good
at doing that and I think local 58 was
the one even though it wasn't the first
analog horror it was the one that kind
of opened up the possibilities for
everybody I guess and like got other
people interested in doing their own
series and I will say that a lot of them
did kind of rip that off like pretty
blatantly but some of the ripoffs were
pretty good too and I don't like I said
I don't want to be uncharitable about
that because the cool thing about analog
horror is that it's really collaborative
like I said and and you know nobody has
copyrights on their IPs or anything like
that really um so you just put up stuff
cuz you want to and if other people want
to make a series in your Universe like
with your lore like you can do that and
a lot of creators that are first
starting out like when they're teenagers
and something um they'll do kind of the
same thing that you know Slender Man for
example did for fiction writers it's a
you know it's a character that already
exists that came from forchan originally
just came from a photo and people just
started writing stories about it and now
there's like this massive [__] lore
about this just this random skinny guy
skinny guy that somebody stuck in a
photo like a long time like somebody
photoshopped into a photo a long time
ago and they just but that's kind of
cool because everyone just keeps
building on it so how do you find this
stuff do you just search for it do you
search for you analog horror and it
would C up it it seems like a lot of um
or is it hidden it's not really so much
hidden it's there but the thing about it
is that there's so much stuff on YouTube
that a lot of times if you don't know
what you're looking for um I kind of
like there's a lot of channels that
cover analog horror like nexo is
probably one of the best known ones and
he'll do like real deep Dives on you
know his videos are like an hour or two
hours long about the lore behind certain
Series so like if he likes a certain
series like he'll do like a big long
video about it and then like its
popularity will usually get like a lot
lot more so so he's usually like a good
bellweather of which ones are good or
which ones are successful like if he
notices it and starts talking about it
then usually it'll get more popular and
I feel like there's kind of like you
know Reddit boards and stuff like the um
threads and stuff where people talk
about ones that they like because the
video we were watching last night the um
the um what do you call it the the
iceburg one he actually mentioned a
couple like way down in his tier six or
whatever that he really liked but that
didn't have that many views because the
thing about it is that analog horror it
really kind of started to take off you
know 2016 2017 something like that and
then by the time 2020 2021 came along it
was starting to get a little bit
oversaturated like everybody was trying
to make one and a lot of them were kind
of syy so there were so many that it
wasn't kind of like the old days where
you could just like drop this enigmatic
video like on YouTube and like just
people would find it and be like holy
crap look at this weird [__] because it
was just so much of it yeah so it it was
a lot harder to get noticed especially
because a lot of the ones that were
coming out were so similar to ones that
had already been done like you know what
I mean and I I don't know like I you
know I'm a creative person myself I
don't make analog horror obviously
although I have thought about doing a
project like that but um what's up Oscar
hey Oscar what's up yeah um I just feel
like I I wouldn't like
to play in someone else's sandbox in the
sense of like taking their lore and
making I I know like a lot of people
start out like that like writing fanfic
or you know like I said doing like you
know writing Slender Man stories or
making an analog horror thing based on
Marble Hornets are based on um five
night Five Nights at Freddy's there's a
lot of those uh based on Five Nights at
Freddy's so I don't know but but I
understand why people want to do that
and if they want to do that if they just
want to take some lore because it's
um that I don't know if I'd necessarily
look easier for them but maybe it's
makes them feel better to be like oh
well I already have like an existing
framework that I can work within and it
makes it easier for them or kind of gets
their confidence up because a lot of
people that started out making sort
of like I said I don't want to say
ripoff but I can't like think of a
better word that made omage Let's okay
let's say homages that made like omes to
other analog horror like a lot of them
went on to do their own creative
projects later on so I think like a good
you know even though I wouldn't do it
like I you know I wouldn't go oh I'm
going to make an analog horror and it's
going to be set in the Five Nights at
Freddy's universe but you know that's
exactly what that one what was that one
called the Walton files that's what that
and that was hugely successful but I
just wouldn't I don't know I I'm I kind
of like to come up with my own ideas but
I see
how like I said it's cool because it's
kind of like a low barrier to entry and
we got to come up with one I've thought
about it like I said it's kind of
probably at this point everyone's kind
of sick of them yeah but um we might be
able to take a different take a
different well see and that's what I'm
kind of hoping happens because it's
gotten to a point now where like some
come out that are like parodies just
because because there are so many
well-known tropes it's like here's a
popped up distorted face and you know
what I mean it's just you know and this
here's the emergency broadcast noise and
stuff like that so there have been so
many that use those same tropes over and
over again you know it's kind of like
the kind of like just the regular horror
movie equivalent of a jump scare like a
cat jump scare let's to be more specific
you know it's a cat flies in the window
oh my God it's just a cat you know what
I mean so it's that kind of [__] so it's
become so those tropes have become
ubiquitous that now people are making
parody videos of it and once you start
doing parody videos then it's kind of
start time to go back to the drawing
board and like start over because I feel
like I don't know there's a lot you
could do with that concept still I would
make I'd make a a fake 1970s news report
Port where you're on location all right
where they've just uncovered a a body
Stash from some serial killer and you
just make up a serial killer that never
existed I've thought about doing that
yeah and you show the bodies and
everything you'd have to the thing about
it is that the reason that I didn't want
to do that cuz there are some that are
sort of like that but um you kind of get
into a little bit of a gray area there
because you don't want to use real
photos of like real dead people you
would have to make it yourself yeah do
it yourself yeah but you make it you you
make it real low res and age it so it
looks like it was like a local
television station back like in
72 they and they accidentally found some
[__] they were just you know breaking
news we just happen to you know go by a
whole bunch of [__] people dead on
the side of the road and you got to have
like a weird [__] angle on it you
know why are they in these positions
that kind of [__] yeah there's like I
said there's a lot of [__] you could do
with it and even if because look
everything you in horror has been done
okay everything and if you can think of
it somebody's done it somewhere even
though if it wasn't famous or popular or
anything like that somebody's done it
somewhere I can guarantee it so the
challenge then becomes to take what's
already been done and try to find a
fresh angle on it because there's always
a fresh angle on it yeah you got to have
it you're the first off the crime scene
you're recording it then the cops show
up kick you off the crime scene that
kind of [__] that'd be awesome yeah like
said and I think there have been some
like that there don't seem to be as many
crime-based ones as paranormal based
ones cuz I think people you can do more
with the Paranormal kind of [__] I guess
but um I was saw one the other day that
was they were talking about one on the
on one documentary I was watching that
and I can't remember what it was called
but it was kind of had to do with like
murders but it was like child murders
and stuff like that so some people were
just kind of like it was a little bit it
was kind of [__] up you know what I
mean like it was kind of popular but
then like as it went on it kind of got
more and more [__] up and people were
like e I'm not really yeah not really
feeling this to and Jen Ross got a nice
ring to speaking of rings we got wedding
rings we finally got our that was that
one got one and he finally got his too
it took me three times to get one that
fit on his finger
yeah I had I have the ring measurement
thing but for some reason I measured his
finger the first time and then I ordered
that ring it was way too small and then
I was like well [__] and I got like a
size and a half up and then I got that
one then we got that one and that one
was also too small and then finally I
was like [__] it I'm just getting two
sizes bigger and then finally that fit
it took like forever but they did take
the other ones back so you know what I
mean so yeah so there's that I think I
already covered this stuff too about
how about 15 minutes yeah I know I'm I
can see the little clock you know what I
mean yeah what time we have to uh we
have to leave here at what 9:30 well it
yeah about 9:30 we should probably leave
by 9:30 because it opens at 10: so we
got another about a half hour for show
yeah something like that okay um so yeah
you're like I said you're also going to
see
um one thing that they do a lot and
local 58 did this and a lot of other
ones do this as well uh is taking
already existing public domain media
which which like I said I think that's
kind of the appeal of this for people
that don't have a lot of time to create
their own content is doing much like
Vapor wave would do where they're taking
this kind of old forgotten media and
like remixing it and putting it in in a
new context so you know you'll find this
cache of weird old training films from
the 1940s or you know strange
commercials that don't make any sense or
something like that and you'll just kind
of take those but remix them to like
make them even more Sinister like so
you're taking something that is
seemingly very mundane and making it
creepy you know like and it's weird
because we were talking about when we
were talking about the max hedum
incident the [__] that he said and the
[__] that he was doing is not scary no
it's bu inside jokes he's talking about
people yeah you don't know who he's
talking about it's not scary but people
still this many [__] decades later
people still talk about that just
because I guess the the act itself was
so weird and the fact that it was never
explained yeah like I said the when
there's no context to something it's a
lot creepier because you're not really
sure like why did this happen so your
imagination just starts going crazy the
channel Wang did a good uh show on it I
think it's probably last about a half
hour and and from what I remember Wang
had uh got on to some pretty good leads
about who it was and it was I think
that's where I got the uh got the
information that it was somebody that
worked worked there at one time that
would make sense because some of the
stuff that he was saying sounded like
like you said kind of like inside jokes
he talking about specific people joking
about people that he worked with type of
deal yeah that evidently were still in
there he was also talking to his friends
yeah he talking to his friends who knew
he was doing it right that was another
thing that he was doing High Desert said
I would love to see a found footage type
story based on searching for Egyptian
mummies in the Grand Canyon as if they
were in the Grand Canyon well may egy
was huge huh maybe there's some way that
they got there like you could you know
if you're a writer you could come up
with some way that they could plausibly
got there you know what I mean you had
to make out with something scary that's
yeah they had a dimension door right
that's what it was a star game they went
yeah they went to any Desert that they
knew of they were trying to find these
other deserts even though Egypt wasn't
really that much of a desert back in
those days it was but was wasn't as bad
as it is now
yeah um another thing too that a lot of
uh analog horror does is they pretty
much I don't know about universally but
almost universally I think they all have
like um unhappy endings like it's
always whatever the whatever the monster
is like gets in what's the one um I
don't even remember if this one was
local 58 or if it was one or it was um
the Gemini one what's the one where it
said like basically that it was all of
these kind of um you know had like an
American flag in it and it was like my
fellow Americans Yad yada and just like
basically like The American or the
aliens have like taken over so it's
telling you to like kill yourselves and
your family and so like that so the
aliens can't take us alive and all this
other kind of stuff but like the way
it's worded and it looked just like
those old like kind of patriotic sort of
uh what what do they call those like the
things they put on TV like the um
commercials and stuff and it kind of
looked like that and it was like kind of
creepy just the [__] that it said
because a lot of them don't
show yeah a lot of them show like weird
imagery it's usually like kind of
distorted faces or shadowy figures or
something like that but a lot of it a
lot of the scariness like kind of comes
from one the inexplicable nature of what
it is you're looking at because you're
not really sure what it is or where it's
coming from and a lot of it comes from
the text too like if you read the text
and it just gets like creepier and
creepier so there's that kind of [__]
too so you know as I said not been
around for a hugely long time but um you
know local 58 probably the one that sort
of kicked off the the Boom in it which
is sort of I feel like it's kind of
starting to Abate now especially since
skinic came out in when did that come
out 2021 maybe
2022 um which was kind of like the first
big analog horror
film um and a lot of people saw it and a
lot of people were talking about it and
I think that brought a lot of new
attention to the subg genre as well
which maybe got a lot more people into
it but like I said at this point it just
seems a little bit over saturated maybe
um you know so there's
holy
crap and I was going to say too I think
I mentioned it earlier but if you
haven't seen the movie um broadcast
signal intrusion I think it's from
2021 um that's really good I did a
review of it I can't remember if I did
it on flickers of fear or maybe over my
scarce law Channel but I did a review of
IT a while back and if you're into
analog horror if you're into like
conspiracy type stuff or cuz it's kind
of loosely based on the not necessarily
on the max hrum but on that kind of
thing where like there's a weird signal
intrusion like and they're trying to
figure out like there's an investigation
to like where it came from but it's like
a really good I mean I don't know I
really liked the movie a lot so um so
yeah I think I talked earlier about how
the whole analog horror thing is sort of
linked
with um Creepy Pasta which is sort of
like the fictional equivalent I suppose
um because it's the same kind of thing
where people are writing these stories
and trying to make people think that
they really happened and then other
people take that concept and and like
write their own stories within that
Mythos which is kind of the same thing
uh that they're doing with this I
believe it was local 58 also that gave
the subg genre its name because one of
its video he didn't mean to obviously
but um one of the videos said um analog
horror at 476 MHz and so people just
started calling the genre that like
after that um came out and I'm pretty
sure the guy that did I didn't even
realize this until I was watching this
documentary but the guy that did um
local
58 is the same guy that did Candle Cove
if you guys remember that very very
famous Creepy Pasta which is about
because I mean local 58 was like an
offshoot of Candle Cove Candle Cove was
about this really really weird creepy
kids show that was on this channel and
then he later on made a whole thing
about that channel that that show was on
and if you've never seen there was a
Sci-Fi original series I believe it's on
shutter or it was last time I checked um
that's called Channel Zero and each
season they take like kind of a
well-known creepy pasta and you know
adapt it basically and I think the first
season or the second season was Candle
Cove and it was really really good cuz
that's like a really creepy story I they
also did they also did um [__] man what
was the name of that one where they were
down in their garage and then all of a
sudden this door appeared that wasn't
there before I love [__] like that that
was a good one too but I can't remember
the name of the story but that was also
a good one I didn't see all the seasons
but I saw the first like two or three
but it's a good show if you haven't seen
it like I said I'm pretty sure it's on
shudder um but yeah so let me see I'm
kind of jumping around I think I talked
about my nose is getting stuffed up like
crazy for some reason is it really you
got to run there and blow my nose
constantly yeah I've been taking
antihistamines try try to get it to Poor
Tom terrible yeah it is um I think I
already talked about NO3 Road I've
talked about local 58 a little bit uh
there's another one called chss that's
another big one and that first came out
in
2016 and that was made by a guy named
turkey Lenin III turkey Lennon yeah like
you know uh so he's actually from
Singapore and like I said a lot of these
when he first put his first video out he
was 15 years old so a lot of these
people like teenagers putting this stuff
out like you said they have time and
yeah are obviously a lot more media
Savvy but chss is actually about a like
a mental health program like that the
government the US government like um you
know it's under their op or whatever and
then there's kind of like I don't know
it just gets weirder and weirder like as
time goes on it's it has a little bit of
an ARG kind of uh vibe to it as well
because I think it also has like Twitter
and it has like other its own website
and all this other kind of stuff because
there's kind of it there's kind of a
gray area between something being an
analog horror like just a series and
something being an ARG I feel like
ARG one it has to have stuff outside of
the series like it has like a website
that reports that this is stuff is
really happening and it has like all of
this outside media actually some args
have even had like physical media you
know what I mean it's like they'll leave
clues for people and like leave actual
[__] like in a park someplace or
somewhere like that like for people to
find which I always thought was really
really cool when those first started to
appear in the late 90s when it messing
around the internet we we couldn't tell
the difference between what was real and
fake yeah thought some of that stuff was
real yeah like so got a crime case down
in Mississippi we were wondering what
does that really going on because we
were in Mississippi at the time right
you know what I mean f it was weird it
wasn't though was a fake case yeah I
mean the kind of the whole well the
whole point of an
ARG is it's you know alternate reality
game you're it's supposed to look as
realistic as possible so you're supposed
to set everything up if somebody
stumbles across it to think this is a
real this is a real [__] that happened
yeah and back then when you were young
you didn't usually you didn't run into
it yourself your friends would tell you
about it you'd be driving in the car
listening to music and they're talking
about it before you ever saw it this is
before you know cell phones with
internet access long before that so you
couldn't check anything until much later
maybe you forgotten about it so there
just be like these ongoing Mysteries
yeah you know there's something going on
up in [__] what you call it really oh
yeah they're killing people s killer up
there you know you could be anything but
right the person telling you this Stu
doesn't know that they saw that was an a
ARG that they saw yeah you they think
it's real so you're like oh wow okay
yeah know just it was another time I
love the concept of an Argy but like I
said I can see how it can muddy the
waters a little bit because the whole
point of an ARG is to make it look as
realistic as possible that's you're
you're supposed to be immersed in the
game like it's really happening right
you know what I mean so they and and a
lot of the creators work really hard to
to get that across yeah we didn't know
that better lock them
doors I mean you should anyway so you
never know there's probably a real
There's real serial killers running
around too like you know other than all
the fake ones DVD Dragon said when is
Tom going to rev that motorcycle again I
got low te yeah because when I was doing
the live stream yesterday I think you
were down there like revving the
motorcycle and I said something like oh
I don't know if you guys can hear that
he's like cuz you were working on the
motorcycle in the garage it was a bu
xp12 R Sr really and D Dragon said said
oh my my testosterone level just went up
just hearing hell yeah hearing theot 103
horsepower 45 103 horsepower 9 5 foot
pounds of torque in a [__] 400lb
motorcycle hell yeah that'll put some
hair on you it's not fast but it's quick
put hair on your B very quick yeah that
[__] that [__] uh 1/8 of a mile
will beat a Hayabusa off from a dead
stop hell
yeah yeah you could do a wheelie in any
gear pretty much you know how to do it
you better not be doing that oh I'm sure
you're doing it when I'm not looking he
does all kind of [__] when I'm not
looking probably and then doesn't tell
me about it yeah he only got five gears
anyway yeah let's see I already talked a
little bit about Marble Hornets I kind
of feel like most people know that's
kind of like the big one and that's made
into a movie and everything and like I
said the crazy thing about Marble
Hornets is that that started it didn't
invent Slender Man Slender Man was like
I said that was like a 4chan it was like
it was like a photo contest like come up
with some creepy [__] or something and
it was one that went viral it was just
like photos of like a bunch of kids
running and then somebody put what would
we would today know as Slender Man like
in the background and then people just
started writing stories about this so
Marble Hornets was um a web series that
was based on that character and it went
on and on and on I think it started in
2009 and it just went on forever and I
think it even had like a um what it's
got like 87 videos or 90s something
videos and it's got like a bunch of
videos over on its other little spin-off
which is called to the ark I actually
started watching Marble Hornets um for a
while but it's like I don't know I
couldn't really get into it like some
like the first bit of it was good but
then I was just kind of like I don't
know I thought I kind of started
thinking it was getting a little too
convoluted but maybe that was just me I
should maybe like give it another go one
of these days but cuz a lot of people
did seem to like it like I said it was
so popular that they made a movie in
2015 that was based on it called always
watching which which was not great but
uh yeah Gemini home entertainment which
somebody brought up before that was kind
of another big one and that was slightly
more recent that actually started in
2019 and that one is kind of similar
concept to local 58 it's kind of like um
it the channel is supposedly a
distributor of VHS tapes it's obviously
doesn't really exists but you know
they're pretending like it does and
their um it's kind of like these tapes
that are showing up that
are showing all these different like
weird incidents around the world that
have to do like with alien creatures
like I said um and it has something the
main antagonist of Gemini home
entertainment is the iris which is
like a rogue Planet but it's a being
like it's intelligent you know what I
mean so that's kind of part of that lore
there so like I said a lot of them that
are real popular have have that kind of
similar Trope where it's some kind of
cosmic horror antagonist I feel like
it's either aliens or it's usually like
some love crafy kind of [__] or like a
transdimensional being or something um I
also mentioned the Walton files earlier
which is based on Five Nights at
Freddy's which I kind of feel like not
just like local 58 has its all own like
off whole sub genre of offshoots I kind
of feel like Five Nights at Freddy's
also has a whole sub genre of offshoots
and can we talk about has anybody seen
the new Five Nights at Freddy's movies I
I haven't seen it but um can we talk
about why a couple years back they made
Will's Wonderland with Nicholas Cage
which was essentially Five Nights at
Freddy's but called something completely
different you know and then it was I
don't know it was just weird to me that
they made that and then they made a Five
Nights at Freddy's movie like this year
I don't I know I didn't get it I'm like
how many like I it's a cool concept I'm
not saying that like with the animatron
like the cursed or haunted animatronics
and stuff but it's just like it doesn't
seem like a broad
enough topic or a broad enough premise
to justify all of the media that's been
written about I what I'm saying is I'm
not really sure why Five Nights at
Freddy like the premise behind Five
Nights at Freddy's why it struck such a
core
to an extent that like there's a whole
Sub sub genre of people
making content based on that lore cuz it
seems like kind of it's a cool concept
it's just kind of narrow maybe I don't
know I haven't watched all of the stuff
so I don't really know maybe it is like
much larger than I thought but isn't
there like a serial killer involved and
he kills kids and puts them inside the
animatronics or something isn't it
something like that I don't know I don't
know but it's just it's crazy to me that
that was one of the ones that was like
super D popular cuz it just seems like
kind of a n premise that's all um also
the Mandela catalog that's another uh
real famous one and that's another one
that has a lot of ripoffs that is the
one that kind of came up with the
concept of the
alternates this is actually set in
Wisconsin in the
90s and they're the alternates are
basically like
doppelgangers who kind of um Talk their
human counterparts into killing
themselves and then they basically like
take
over uh I think it also kind of has like
a Biblical angle which a lot of people
thought was interesting because that's
not usually something that you see in uh
in analog horror so I so I think that
kind of struck a chord as well but the
concept of the alternates like
doppelgangers and stuff that's really
really popular like after the Mandela
catalog came out like a lot of analog
horror like use that Trope as well um
some other ones I to talk about cuz I
kind of want to talk about the back
rooms
too late what Biblical angle you could
do [__] uh you you could do uh Battle
of armagedon and [__] and and
Revelations right now it'd be it'd be
[__] hot probably yeah yeah you could
misquote the Bible about plagues being
poured out and you know the battle in
[__] over Israel and [__] [__] the
world's armies and Gog and Magog and
[__] I could write I could write some
[__] up that'd be awesome it proba yeah
it probably would yeah I I I'd do most
of it i' [__] uh become like a fake
preacher to deliver it oh that would be
good cuz you're you'd be good at that
hell yeah today the next
thing I'm here to be your shepherd
shepherd you through this times of
hardship yeah yeah I'd go all [__]
Baptist Minister
on yeah yeah people probably believe it
though they yeah they probably would
then they start sending me money and I
keep doing it what's wrong with that I
keep I keep doing it and doing it win
next thing you know I am a [__]
apocalyptic Baptist Minister I'll talk
I'll talk you down from that but you can
take the money though I mean that's okay
if they if they're dumb enough to send
you money then yeah I don't think
there's have been any jacked baptist
ministers [__] T evangelists yet
probably not although I will say that I
believe what is it the 90s or 2000s I
want to say during the height of the
extreme everything um they would have
like in Christian high schools and [__]
like that they would have like Christian
bodybuild dudes come yeah and they would
do for strength yeah and and they would
do like demonstrations like on stage and
be like you know Jesus is making me
strong like that kind of [__] LIF those
weights had nothing do I know but it's
like taking those steroids had nothing
to do with it either I know but that was
that was kind of a thing I remember that
being a thing yeah like around that time
period so there was I think there was
some that did like karate and stuff too
yeah yeah breaking boards for Jesus
breaking boards for Jesus pretty much
well it's like they wanted anything that
would get B kids to come in there and be
like give them something to look at I
guess and then like you know they going
to hammer home the Jesus message like at
the end like after you watch somebody
break boards and yeah you know lift 300
lbs or whatever yeah [__] the Kung Fu
guys are [__] talking about throwing
she bballs and [__] that
just I just threw a think name was tman
what yeah yeah I don't know yeah no but
yeah now the Mandela catalog one of the
things in that was that Lucifer um is
actually disguising himself as the
Archangel Gabriel that's like one aspect
of the plot too you see an angel don't
believe that's the devil yeah that's
yeah um so let's see there was another
more recent one called the smile tapes
that was from 2021 that had a pretty
that was actually kind of about a drug
that's called smile and people that take
it it kind of makes them smile and laugh
uncontrollably so that one has like a
lot of distorted face kind of stuff
going on um and I think the cause ends
up being like some kind of
extraterrestrial fungus that's another
pretty common thing like fungus like
they got that from Batman with a smile x
c yeah yeah probably well like I said
there's you know the people are drawing
inspiration from all different kind of
stuff and then one of the weirder ones I
think is uh the monument
Mythos and that's kind of like it's sort
of analog horror it's also kind of like
alternate history it was made by this
guy whose name is Mr R manticor and
there's I don't know where he came up
with this [__] idea it's so Random
there's okay so the premise of it I'm
not really sure because I haven't seen
all of them so I don't really know if I
can explain it adequately but so there's
three universes now the the main
Universe in the story is called the dean
verse and that's where James Dean is the
37th President of the United States wow
they're alternate histories like I yeah
yeah yeah um now
I think in that Universe I think the
Earth gets destroyed like at the end
like with only a few survivors left and
then um so all the events leading up to
this apocalypse have been um sort of
like documented by this person who has
uploaded the videos to YouTube under
audm there's also a second Universe
which is called the Nixon verse um where
Richard Nixon is was in the James Dean
universe but then he gets transplanted
to the other ones but he also gets like
God Powers somehow I don't really know
how di it becomes God pretty much okay
and so then there's that and then
there's a third Universe which is called
the Montie which is has Montgomery Clif
in it who was a famous actor from a long
time ago um and he also runs as
president but James Dean is his vice
president so there's this whole but it's
it's kind of like an apocalyptic
narrative um but there's just like these
random people from history like being
presidents and having gu powers and [__]
like that it's just so bizarre and like
I said I'm not really sure and I think
one of the main things in it is that the
reason it's called The Monument Mythos
is because all of the main monuments
around the world like particularly in
the United States and Sh like like the
Statue of Liberty and stuff like have
some kind of stuff in them like some
kind of alien stuff or transdimensional
beings or something like that or they're
alive I can't remember it's been a while
since I've seen it but it has something
to do with all the like monuments and
you know like Mount Rushmore and [__]
like that so it's that's kind of crazy
so yeah I think we mentioned Corner folk
before so let's talk about the thing
that kind of took off in
19 uh called the back rooms now this is
an analog
Horror
concept that originated kind of like
Slender did it originated with a single
photo on
4chan the photo which is you know went
viral so most people are probably seen
it but it was just this random photo
nobody really knows where it was taken
but of these kind of empty hallways with
this sort of
yellow carpet and this kind of ugly
yellow wallpaper and it's creepy looking
for reasons that aren't real um easy to
categorize you know what I'm saying but
it really seemed to strike a cord with
um a lot of people like this creepy
photo because what it was I think that
somebody basically on this 4chan board I
think it was like the Paranormal board
on
4chan and they asked people to just post
images I think it was post disquieting
images that just feel off that was the
prompt I guess so one of the pictures
was this one which had been floating
around for a year but when it was posted
on for it kind of went crazy and like
everybody picked up on it
and somebody commented I didn't see it
after that
photo um you showed it no I didn't show
it I don't have it but like I said it's
easy to find it's it's
everywhere so somebody posted after the
photo this
paragraph they said if you're not
careful and you no clip out of reality
in the wrong areas you'll end up in the
back rooms where it's nothing but the
stink of old moist carpet The Madness of
mon yellow cuz the stuff was the carpet
and the wallpaper was yellow the endless
background noise of fluorescent lights
at maximum hum buzz and approximately
600 million square miles of randomly
segmented empty rooms to be trapped in
oh man that's so I've had dreams like
that yeah so I think like I said so I
think the combination of the photo which
is pretty creepy for like I said reasons
you can't really articulate and the fact
that somebody commented that paragraph
afterward made everybody's imagin ations
just go crazy so what they what people
started doing was started creating a
lore about the back rooms where it was
this where you could kind of essentially
like slip into another
dimension and you would go into this
place that was just endless endless
rooms rooms and hallways with nothing in
them and nobody in them and there was
like No Way Out yeah I had dreams like
that deep underneath the ground I think
a lot of people have yeah deep
underneath the ground with no windows
had another one where I was trapped into
a mall and it had people in the mall but
every escalator I went every time I
tried to leave the mall I ended up being
teleported back somewhere else inside
the mall I could never actually get out
of the mall I would go up an escalator
and then when as I reached the top of
the escalator I was down at the bottom
of the escalator again yeah that was
another thing that was weird see that's
a very nightmarish scenario and I think
that a lot of people have yeah
nightmares like that and I think that's
kind of why the back rooms took off in
such a way um because everybody can
relate to those horrible nightmares that
you have where you're just inop yeah it
was just like endless loops and you
can't get out and it's just like that's
really really scary I think that's a
pretty common dream to have so as time
went on I think the most um popular
video I can't remember the name of the
kid that made it but um he kind of made
one where it's just these as it took him
like a month to make it or something and
it's just like all these yellow it's
basically like a you know POV like you
went into these back rooms and you're
just like walking around there's like
nothing and then there's like weird [__]
like you know a car crashed into the
wall or something and then like there's
kind of a monster sort of after you but
you can't really see him all that well
it's actually really well done but I
think that's most what most people think
of when they think of the back rooms but
the thing about it is that it kind of
went into much like you know the Slender
Man became the Slender verse where where
everybody started writing all this lore
and stories about it and the same thing
kind of happened with back rooms like I
said it really struck a chord and people
started adding onto the lore they
started adding like levels to it like it
was a game there's games designed around
it there's all these kind of stories
around it and I kind I don't know
they're they're making a a24 is making a
feature film based on the back room's
concept I don't know when it's coming
out but I've heard that they're making
it and I'm not really sure how I feel
about it like you could make a really
good movie out of that concept but I
feel
like the creepy thing about the original
photo and the original video that the
kid made was that there was like I said
not really any context basically the
only context was this is like a
dimension that you could slip into and
his thing was here's somebody that's
just um you know this uh kind of
scientific research thing that's kind of
trying to figure out what it is yeah you
know what I mean so it's essentially
it's a little bit like in stranger
things like the upside down you know
what I mean like it's just like another
dimension which kind of looks like this
one but a bit different but I kind of
feel like if they try to overe explain
it and I think at this point it maybe
has been overexplained just with all of
the outside lore that it has because
people keep adding like I said new level
in sub basements and all this other kind
of stuff and explaining where it came
from and who the monsters are in it and
stuff like that you keep doing that and
it's not going to be scary anymore you
know what I'm saying yeah we we were
talking about that before that the
more the more you gild the Lily the more
you kind of put explain things and the
more you put things in there like the
less frightening it is it's much more
frightening when it's
just that it's just that like you know
what I mean cuz you can imagine what if
you were just walking
through a mall or something and you went
back to use the bathroom and you open
the door and then you were in there and
you're like you couldn't get out like
that would be [__] horrifying right
but no explanation you don't need to
know why it's like that you don't need
know why it's there there didn't even
have to be a monster in it really I
think the back rooms thing the monster
in it is cool but I don't think it even
needed the monster cuz I think the whole
concept by itself is creepy and so when
the back rooms went viral it kind of
brought to the Forefront the idea of a
Lial space
and I think that's kind of another thing
that you see a lot with you know the
vapor wave uh kind of Trends and dead
Mall videos things like that and I think
the
fascination with dead malls is because
people are fascinated in general with
Lial spaces now Lial spaces it's usually
described as something like that's in
between like a hallway or something but
in the modern parlons I think that most
people use it to designate the feeling
that you get from seeing a place that's
usually really crowded with people that
is that has no people in it yeah no
longer has a purpose yeah that too and
people and there's a very specific
emotion that that brings up in
people and so so I think the back rooms
is really good at um you know the whole
concept of it was really good at kind of
making people feel that like I said
obviously because it really struck a
chord and the whole dead Mall thing
struck a chord you wouldn't think if
okay if you went back in time 20 years
ago for something and you told people
that millions of people would be
watching videos of a dude just walking
around an empty shopping mall yeah a
dying shopping mall yeah people would
think you were [__] crazy that like
people would entertain themselves
watching that and how much money that
time is worth to of Television
corporation like wait a minute they they
spent [__] 6 hours a week watching
that that's billions of dollars [__]
advertising space yeah cuz [__] I have
sat there and watched hours and hours of
Dan Bell just walking around yeah we put
those malls YouTube put those [__]
under though you that model no longer
exists um we got about probably three
minutes yeah yeah we'll we'll go in a
minute but yeah so so like I said I
think that the whole I think it's the
same a little bit of the same feeling
that you see with um you know Urban
exploration where and particularly when
people find abandoned houses where all
the [__] is still there especially if
it's a mansion that's weird yeah like
when you showed me that one that was a
mansion that it's like you know
obviously looks kind of [__] up
because it's been abandoned for a while
but it was um surprisingly intact and a
lot of the people's [__] was still there
like clothes and toys and so I'm
thinking to myself and I think a lot of
people think this why it's creepy and
fascinating it's just like what the [__]
what was the situation that happened
that caused them to just leave all their
[__] here like they lose all their money
they can't afford I guess but it's like
you think that they would at least take
some of their things well they they
sometimes they have the story sometimes
they know uh they dude loses all his
money wife divorces him she takes
everything they no longer have enough
money to move a lot of that [__] out of
the [__] apartment right and and what
do they want with all that [__]
furniture they can't move it to another
to a smaller house where they're going
but even the clothes and toys and stuff
you that was kind of like their old
clothes yeah I guess their newer clothes
they took and you know the kid the kids
had outgrown those toys they left them
they didn't want to spend thousands and
thousands of dollars of moving all that
[__] into a little bitty house and was
more than one house because a lot of
times the family's breaking up the kid
doesn't live with them anymore the
kids's grown now kind what it is yeah
but yeah I think that's kind of whole
because honestly I really like well in a
way that kind of creeps me me out there
there's kind of a whole sub genre too of
like stock photos which I really like of
just like photographs of like empty
rooms like especially ones that are sort
of like retro like the one that I use
for the um for the thumbnail which is
just like kind of like a retro TV and
like a lamp but then there's like nobody
in there yeah and it's I don't know it's
just like really hard to explain like
why that's so creepy there's nothing
inherently creepy about like an empty
room obviously but obviously there is
because a lot of people think that and
that's why that that's why it's used so
much in particularly nowadays like in um
you know in back rooms and skin rank
used that a lot like you know looking at
like empty corners and [__] like that
it's just [__] creepy you know what I
mean yep okay we're uh we're we're out
all right so we are going to go out so
we have to sign off for the evening I
think we mostly stayed on topic that's
amazing yeah yeah yeah yeah nice little
[__] we we stayed on topic more than we
usually do yeah we got go but yeah we uh
we really have to get going get down
there and have our Thanksgiving Eve goth
party so uh so yeah so hopefully you
guys enjoyed the show uh if you're just
arriving now obviously uh really sorry
but we have to sign off so hopefully you
can watch it recorded later on uh as I
said please remember to click on the
skill share link in the bottom get 50%
off of a monthly or an annual
subscription uh you know it's down in
the in the description box if you would
so we will see you guys again on Friday
night for the Sidetrack show please have
a Happy Thanksgiving if you are in the
United States or if you're celebrating
it elsewhere and we will see you guys
again on Friday good night